welcome to the man of recaps this is
fantastic beasts the crimes of
grindelwald remember at the end of the
first movie sexy colin farrell revealed
that he was secretly working with the
evil wizard grindelwald but our hero
newt scamander used one of his magical
creatures to capture him but turns out
he wasn't just working for grindelwald
he was grindelwald in disguise it's not
colin farrell it's albino johnny depp so
now grindelwald's imprisoned in america
but it's time to transfer him over to
europe but wait that's not the real
grindelwald he pulled the same trick
again and now grindelwald is free over
in england newt scamander is still an
awkward animal lover but now he must
face a new type of fantastic beast a
girl this is leda lestrange who we
briefly learned in the first movie was
newt's high school crush but now she
just got engaged to newt's brother who's
a serious ministry or in fact the
ministry wants a news help to track down
the creepy orphan kid he met in the
first movie credence yes remember
because he repressed his magic it turned
into an obscurus a super strong cloud
monster we thought he died at the end of
the first movie but turns out he
survived and now the ministry wants to
kill him before grindelwald can recruit
him what is grindelwald's deal well he's
got sort of a classy calm demeanor that
makes him seem like a good guy but his
philosophy is that wizards are superior
to muggles and should be ruling them and
for some reason credence is a big part
of his plan they think he's the
long-lost son of a pure blood family and
is part of some prophecy now there's
someone else who wants a new help too it
is young sexy dumbledore he also wants
newt to go find credence but not to kill
him to befriend him so he becomes a good
guy but newt scamander's like wait a
second why am i in this movie there's no
magical animals involved it's like yeah
we accidentally committed to calling
this series fantastic beasts so we're
gonna have to squeeze some in there and
indeed did new tas are a really cool
apartment that's basically a big magical
animal rescue newt's adventures rescuing
magical creatures could have been a cool
spin-off series or something but in this
movie it's irrelevant to the plot
speaking of plot to relevance newt gets
a visit from his new american friends
queenie goldstein and jacob kowalski
remember jacob's a muggle so at the end
of the last movie they had to give him
the rain amnesia but his love for
queenie was too strong it didn't stick
and now these two are gonna get married
and they came to england to do it
because in america wizard muggle
marriages are illegal but jacob's acting
really weird and pretty soon it's
obvious queenie has him under a love
spell he does actually love her but he
didn't support the marriage thing
because he doesn't want queenie to get
in trouble and she's like babe if you
really loved me you'd help me break laws
so she goes off to visit her sister tina
who knew had kind of a romance with less
movie but teen is real mad at him right
now because in his brother's engagement
announcement there was a misprint it
said it was newt that's marrying leeda
and turns out tina's on the job in paris
looking for credence so it's a bro road
trip to win their girlfriend's back and
maybe stop grindelwald along the way so
welcome to magical paris where they're
having a carnival credence is in france
looking for his birth family but instead
for now he's found a new girlfriend at
the circus she has a rare curse where
she can turn into a snake but one day it
will be permanent and her name is nagini
so yeah voldemort's future snake used to
be a person anyway for now clarence
helps her escape and now all the magic
animals are on the loose so tina does
not find credence here but she does fine
to this totally random dude so newt gets
to town it's like oh missing magical
creatures that's something i could
actually help with but his first
priority is finding tina so he tracks
his random dude down but turns out oh
he's a bad guy who locks him in a cell
but then with no explanation he decides
to just take a nap they'll decide to
ignore this for now because the giant
flower lion is rampaging paris and newt
actually gets to do some magical
creature wrangling now he tries to tell
tina he's not actually engaged but
because he's an awkward guy stuck in a
poorly written movie he just can't come
out and say it and then they're
distracted by a grindelwald attack he
sends his dirty bed sheets to cover all
of paris this is how he announces
there's a big grindelwald rally tonight
because there's no twitter yet so now
the plot finally begins as newt and tina
have to stop grindelwald by um doing
something with credence wait why are
they even in this movie and just as
everyone's about to fall asleep whoa
what's this we're going back to hogwarts
yes sexy young dumbledore is a brilliant
professor but the ministry of magic is
mad at him it's like yo bro you're the
only one strong enough to fight
grindelwald you gotta do it but he just
says i can't now we kind of know from
harry potter and the deathly hallows
that dumbledore and grindelwald used to
be best friends and implied lovers and
back then they made a magical pact never
to fight one another because i mean what
are the chances one of us would become
evil so now grindelwald wants to recruit
credence but we still don't fully know
why and he's trying to tempt him with
truth of his real identity so now newton
tina must save the world with an epic
adventure to the french ministry
archives looking for credence's birth
certificate newt finally explains he's
not really engaged and tells tina she
has eyes like a salamander which she
takes as a compliment so yeah these two
are made for each other just then lita
shows up looking for her family records
because the suspicion is credence is a
lestrange but the family records have
been moved to the crypt she does join
newton tina though and the evil
librarians mad at him so six the cats on
them and it's a moving bookcases scene
but now newt has a bigger cat and oh
they ride this thing out of there
apparently it can teleport so now we're
at the lestrange crypt and turns out
random guy is here too with credence and
nagini and also jacob if none of this
sounds familiar to you it's because this
is the scene where you finally fell
asleep so random guy finally explains
who he is he was the son of a nice
family but the evil daddy lestrange
liked his mama so put a spell on her to
steal her and she died giving birth to a
daughter lita lestrange this guy loved
his mom so he swore an unbreakable vow
to kill the person that daddy lestrange
loved most but turns out that was not
leta he was a bad dad who never loved
her he did eventually have a son that he
loved and to protect him from this guy
he put him on a boat for america but
when that boat sank everyone thought the
lestrange son was dead but turns out it
is credence and he's alive so sorry you
seem like a nice kid but i swore an
unbreakable bow i have to kill you i
probably should have just sworn the vow
to kill your evil dad himself instead
but now what's this leta lestrange has a
double secret reveal she was on that
boat to america where her annoying baby
brother never stopped crying while the
cabin next door had a nice quiet baby
and oh she did a baby swap and
unfortunately the boat sank before she
could swap back so she accidentally
killed her baby brother and that's
haunted her her whole life so as for
credence's real identity well he's rey
from the last jedi he's just a nameless
orphan like he always thought but now
it's time for the grindelwald rally
jacob finds goldie here who's interested
in grindelwald because of his
progressive views on wizard muggle
marriage yeah he's fine with it he sees
muggles as less than wizards so they
should be able to do whatever they want
with them but he eventually gives his
big pitch about why wizards should rule
muggles and turns out it's about world
war ii it's like yeah muggle
technologies progresses too fast pretty
soon they'll destroy the world we have
to rise up and conquer them to save it
so grindelwald makes a cool ring of fire
like hey if you want to join me come on
in and goldie wants to do it jacob's
like yo girl he's clearly evil but she's
like no it's the only way we could be
together credence wants to join
grindelwald too because apparently he
knows his real secret identity and
nagini gets her first line of the movie
where she's like no don't do it but
credence doesn't listen to her and this
would be much more emotionally impactful
if we got to know her as a character at
all and apparently this was
grindelwald's whole master plan to get
credence to willingly join him on the
dark side leta lestrange might join
grindelwald too but she looks at our
scamander brothers and says i love you
who which one is she talking to but none
of that matters anyway because she was
only pretending to join grindelwald so
she could kill him but she fails
miserably and grindelwald kills her
which again would be much more
emotionally impactful if we got to know
her or newt's brother as a character at
all so grindelwald figures now's the
time for a confusing cgi finale and he
makes a fire dragon to destroy all of
paris but now who's here to save the day
it's nicholas flamel yes the legendary
alchemist who created the sorcerer's
stone for random reasons the gang
crashed at his house earlier where we
got to see that he did indeed unlock the
secret to eternal life but not eternal
youth which kind of defeats the point
but now he leads the remaining wizards
in a massive counterspell to destroy
grindelwald's dragon and our wizards all
work hard making their best constipation
faces and how the day is saved now back
during the rally newt noticed that
grindelwald wore a suspicious piece of
jewelry and so a magical creature
actually gets involved when the niffler
steals it and so our heroes return to
hogwarts even though i'm not really sure
who most of those people are newt's like
hey dumbledore my kleptomol stole your
ex-boyfriend's necklace and so now if
dumbledore can destroy it he can finally
go fight grindelwald right on man well
sounds like you could use some fantastic
beasts as backup so in the next movie
newt scamander is going to continue to
pretend to be the main character as for
grindelwald he reveals that credence
does really have a double secret
identity this time he's rey in the last
skywalker because turns out he actually
is from a famous wizarding family his
real name is allegedly aurelius
dumbledore
yes this random chicken you found is
actually a phoenix the animal of the
dumbledore family so that proves it he
convinces aurelius that his brother
albus is a bad dude so now credence is
fully on grindelwald's side with his
magic powers unlocked and that's where
the crimes of grindelwald comes to an
end
if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
recaps of tv and movies
[Music]